well hi everyone my name is Aaron McKie
aka the Volgin today I have a very
special a very spicy announcement and
that is I am starting finally after
months of people asking I am starting a
patreon for those of you who don't know
what patreon is it's a website where you
can support creators that you like you
can give them a small bit of support
each month and in return you get a
little something back from that creator
for the past 5 years have created audio
adaptations of articles from the SCP
wiki if you don't know what that is
although pretty hard believe you don't
know what that is from watching my
channel but if you don't know what it is
it's a hard based community right in
sight that I was risen in popularity
over the last six or seven years as time
is went on I've put more effort into
trying to make my content look and sign
to the highest quality I can personally
make it it's been a personal goal of
mine since I can remember to make it as
a voice actor on my YouTube and small
farm and how's it like me in a really
small way to do this I've been featured
multiple times and an SCP themed ecdm
called SCP containment bridge and this
game I voiced several characters but the
one I'm most known for is the mysterious
plague doctor scp-049 that's kind of
like a fan favorite so let's get on to
why you should support me because that's
important you need to have a reason
right so the main reason I'm starting
this patreon is that I want to make more
content more consistently for my
listeners because the more financial
support I received I could take more
requests vastly improve the speed in
which I work and improve the quality of
my work all of this means more content
that you will enjoy not to mention the
rewards you get exclusively from patreon
so this could only be a positive step
forward over the last few months have
been gradually stepping on my production
schedule for videos and as I've done
this I've become aware that due to the
HAR nature of some of my videos they're
being deemed inappropriate by certain
companies even though to my knowledge
I've made my content and here to their
advertising guidelines this makes it a
lot harder for me to continue making
content purely supported by odd sense
that being said I know there's still an
audience for what I do I decided to open
up this means of support for people that
appreciate what I do a nine I'm gonna go
through the reward tiers as to what
you'll get if you pledge do you might be
at your own
the first one is Class D these are all
se P thing you're welcome but the first
one is called Class D which is tier one
which is the one dollar a month
everybody has to have that give me one
dollar a month you get access to my
patreon feed which pretty much is I will
post previews of videos that I'm working
on I will run pulls on new videos new
ideas if you get access to my patreon
feed it's a more direct way to give me
feedback in my videos and you've got wee
bit of a sneak preview every month as to
what I might be working on big you know
like a big project so that's tier 1 tier
2 is called junior researcher 5 dollars
a month you get a named credit at the
end of my videos so people know all the
junior researchers that have helped me
create this video now on top of that you
get the previous reward every single
reward tier that goes up you get all of
the previous tier 3 its field agent my
accent sounds really weird when I say
field but field agent this is the TAM
dollars a month tier in this tier you
are invited to join me once a month for
a one hour
discord chat kind of hangout because I
live in the GMT time zone we're gonna
have to work out what time zone suits
the most people any person who becomes a
patron gets access to the patreon side
of my desk cord so we'll be creating
poles as to what is the best time we're
not gonna be able to please everyone I
don't think if I get loads hopefully I
will
so anyway but it but if we get loads
we're gonna have to just schedule a time
and try and please as many people as
possible and then all the previous
rewards no no we're after in territory
right don't think a lot of people are
gonna be planting this a month of money
but if you don't in big you don't get
big so that being said let's move on to
the ridiculous tiers tier four is the
senior researcher position this is
mainly for people who message me on
discord or email me or tweet me or
direct message me in any way saying
would you record something for me
like an intro to a podcast some lines
for a role-playing game a personalized
greeting for somebody with the senior
researcher I will say a personalized
recorded sentence and a voice of your
choice fifty words are less because I
don't want people sending me twenty two
thousand words and going okay here's
twenty five those just get that to me by
tomorrow
thanks know so I've set 50 words or less
generally I'm not gonna be super strict
I mean if it's 60 words I'll probably do
it but if it's if it's a lot more than
50 I'm gonna ask you to rewrite it in
addition to that this is a one-time
sign-in bonus about a couple of years
ago I designed an SCP ID card for people
and I don't do it anymore I used to do
it on reddit for free I did that a
couple of years ago I don't do it
anymore
but for people to choose the senior
researcher position I am willing to
bring it back a make you an ID card know
whenever I make this I will send it to
you in a high-quality PDF print this is
print ready which means that has all the
bleed right in the edges and everything
you can take this to you ever you want
get it printed it'll include your
picture your name you can customize the
color of the card pretty much you can
customize essentially every single
written or visual part of the card
except the layout and then in addition
to that you also get a super patron desk
or drank which means any suggestion that
you give me on this cord
it's a wee bit of a higher priority than
normal patrons okay so tier 505 counsel
in addition to having your name featured
at the end of my videos and a little
list I will end the video with I would
like to say a special thanks to blah
blah blah blah blah blah and structured
name here this is a personalized thank
you because if you're donating $50 the
least I can do is say your name at the
end of the video and then all the
previous rewards I'm finally the tier
that no one is gonna buy tier 6 ethics
committee $100 a month now this is a
video Commission is this that isn't
necessarily SCP this can be anything if
it's a thousand words or less if you
want I'll upload it to my youtube
channel as well and all of the previous
rewards so there you go there that's my
sex reward tiers go over to patreon calm
the whole game check it out see if you
would like to support me it would be
really cool if you would because if I
get some supporters I can stop relying
as much on Adsense to pay my bills so I
can focus more on creating better
content for you and that's the ultimate
goal of this patreon by the way pretty
much to make Adsense obsolete for my
channel so instead of saying to myself
well I won't do that video because the
title is not art friendly and I will
become homeless the next month I can go
yes I will make it because people's
support means I could make it regardless
that's everything thank you very much
for listening to this video if you
choose to support me thank you
it means so much if you don't choose to
support me that's fine just keep
watching this channel and I hope to make
content that you love bye bye
you